good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy tuesday hope
everyone's having a great day i am
having a great day because i'm seated
with you know a regular co-host it's my
husband it's ben boy with no job founder
of
spritsociety.com use codetoast but today
you are on the show as a hero
because something just happened that
honestly
like i see you in a whole new light
we walked into the studio well first of
all welcome to the show thank you
darling um we walked into the studio and
we were like freaking out because there
was crazy construction going on outside
lots of loud noises we didn't know what
to do about the podcast and you said you
were gonna go down and check it out and
then five minutes into you going to
check it out silence so you've just
returned and i want to know what how did
you do that
i went up to the guy in the truck and
asked him to turn off his truck
that's it yeah and i'm here to tell you
kim kardashian said it right i'm gonna
butcher it but if you just get up your
ass and work get off your at no get off
your ass get up off your ass no it's um
get your [ __ ] ass up and work great
so if you get up and you ask the person
who has and they work on they were
receptive you shut it yeah i said hi
we're trying to film a live show
your truck is it's a refrigerator that's
what it was so like it's like they had
delivered the fish and their
refrigerator was still on so like the
next guy that's getting delivery is
gonna get smelly fish but it's not our
problem that's not our problem not at
all oh my god you're a hero i was like
what are we gonna do about the podcast i
was thinking of maybe going home to
record
but you're a hero i gotcha saving the
toes thank you for doing that anytime
welcome back to the show how are you
doing i'm doing wonderful yeah being
wonderful i love coming on the show we
love having you uh great week all great
weeks wonderful passover wonderful
passover some great seders how are you
doing i'm not eating bread i'm doing
well um
just
matzah is just very confusing it's like
it tastes delicious but then really
binds you that's what we were talking
about yesterday and
if you don't eat it then you're really
just dieting like you're not like in
like the passover spirit 100 years on
like a really restrictive diet like keto
key disease totally um and so are you
feeling like you might break your your
hamates no no no no no no no need to
break it you know for sure i'll just
have like terrible stomach pains for the
next week yeah you're feeling bound up
mata is tough like that's it like
i i don't know how else to explain it
it's not a good digestive that's for
sure no it binds you and then it
splinters you and it's yeah we won't get
into it but it's it's no good well i
wanted to update everyone since
yesterday i told everyone about theo's
journey to the vet he did go to the vet
clean bill of health said a lot of you
know his stomach things you know his
refusal to eat might be behavioral or
he's just fighting a little stomach bug
nothing crazy but they did suggest a
teeth cleaning which if you're a dog
parent you know that's something you
really put off because you have to put
your dog under anesthesia which is just
like seems unnecessary but they had an
opening so theo was currently at the vet
he's under anesthesia he's getting his
teeth cleaned but hopefully he's gonna
you know wake up with gorgeous breath
gorgeous teeth and we're just you know
we're worried parents right now yeah
it's scary just because like 17 and a
half pounds anesthesia just doesn't sit
right with me but i'm sure everything
will be fine
and i will say that he was unbelievably
energetic last night and this morning
which makes me think that all the stuff
going on with him was just a stomach bug
yeah but that doesn't change the fact
that he has plaque teeth and yeah we
gotta we gotta get rid of the block he's
about to turn five so like it was time
we've known we should have we like
wanted to do this over the years but now
the doctor said like it's officially
time
um so we're just you know keep theo in
your thoughts and prayers prayers up for
tigs um
hopefully you know he's gonna have
gorgeous teeth and it's all gonna be
good yes yes are you throwing him a
birthday party on the toast tomorrow um
yeah theo's birthday is 4 20 because he
loves to smoke pot
and i was thinking of baking him some
you know weed infused dog treats that's
a good idea yeah maybe i'll get some
balloons for the toast tomorrow yeah
who's on tomorrow
or just have him here she'll love it but
she doesn't know theo so she'll be like
what the [ __ ] is this no she'll
she'll quickly bring him into her heart
to know theo is to love theo exactly so
let's see with you ben before we dive in
i know you're gonna recap fast five with
me which i'm so appreciative for your
time uh everything's wonderful
uh spritz is wonderful
we're launching in a bunch of new
markets or have launched we're now live
in california at your local bevmo or
total one florida total one
illinois we're live in chicago at
foxtrot texas with specs massachusetts
i wasn't supposed to say that that's
tomorrow no way yes we're live in
massachusetts in total wine and actually
a bunch of liquor stores
yeah we're expanding like nicely in
massachusetts yeah and the boston
toasters the bostines like they go
[ __ ] hard like i think there's gonna
be a statewide shortage of of spritz
because like the boss teens are [ __ ]
wild well there should be and if sports
society is not available in your area
you can go to spurtsociety.com and use
code bunge
w nj for 15 off yeah ben gave himself a
higher code than toast like i thought
that was [ __ ] up
you want 15 yeah give the choice back
there fifteen percent it's ten percent
the toast so why is yours more
i don't know because people use it less
[Laughter]
that's smart business i like that so for
today
15 off and maybe another day toast will
be 15. that's okay use your code you
know get all get all your clicks i need
i need some validation on my code use
your code all the way quote bunch bwnj
um
and we have a new flavor launching soon
yeah we do we have like
to use your
terms we have a sickening flavor
launching yes i tasted it like it is so
good
uh and we just have a new
we have a bunch of new stuff coming out
in may
and it's just really exciting new stuff
is is great i love new stuff i love
drinking and i love being on the toast
with you i love being on the toast with
youtube have you been listening catching
up with some of the co-hosts any
favorites in the last you haven't been
on in a couple weeks
no so you haven't listened to one single
episode zero so i support your ventures
but you don't support mine you support
your ventures because it's also your
venture
can i get a cut of the test no
make me a co-owner in the toaster i'd be
happy to listen all step off
um
okay well it's nice to know
oh my god that's what i was singing
school of rock step up
step up
i love that movie if you were a
character in school of rock who would
you be
dewey
no like one of the kids
like which kid did you barnes
the pianos
um no actually i'd probably be
um
like when you were a kid watching the
movie like who did you identify with
no one
how could you possibly identify with
that motley crew i honestly like as much
as it pains me but it's important to
like know thyself i was giving miranda
cosgrove 100
you were her yeah and like i still have
that you have a much better voice than
her yes but like the way she was just
like a leader of the group directing
everyone giving jobs orders bossy
actually sorry olivia is
miranda cosgrove yeah olivia has miranda
cosgrove energy too especially because
her voice is not good
[Music]
hopefully she doesn't listen to today's
episode she will and she'll appreciate
it i don't know i kind of feel like
you're the head of security i could be
you're that guy
that's a good guy i guess yeah he's
legend yeah i mean the whole the movie
is legendary for ben's like wait i
didn't mean dewey is dewey's friend
joey's the teacher well he pretends to
be dewey yeah you didn't mean the real
dude no i'm not the real dewey i was
making sure that you didn't think i was
talking about the real world i knew you
were talking about jack black yeah can
we agree that the worst part is jerry
silverman ever is sarah silverman 100
i think that that movie single-handedly
made her a villain in like 90 percent of
america's eyes i couldn't agree more she
was a [ __ ] vote horrible and i will
say like one bright spot of covey like
very small bright spot was your birthday
where we couldn't do a lot and we went
to the movies in jersey city like it was
a completely empty theater oh no you
rented out a movie theater it was not my
birthday we went to a birthday party oh
yeah it was liors for my friendly or
yeah yeah yeah where where he rented a
movie theater and we watched school of
rock in the theater 99 you can rent a
theater not per person total total so we
threw like maybe 10 or 15 people i
invited taylor striker taylor johnny
here we all like got so many snacks i
think somebody brought like a joint and
we watched school of rock and it was
really like a highlight of my life it
was fantastic a great birthday party
yeah it was great yeah also speaking of
cobid big news yesterday mass mandate
was lifted by the government and
therefore
not enforced by individual airlines so i
think united delta american southwest
most of them jetblue came out and said
they're not enforcing the masks and when
the news came out it's so crazy like you
can be in the air but like you're still
very much like connected with the real
world because people who were in flight
during the announcement from different
airlines like the flight attendants were
like ripping their masks off and like
crying like these people have been
working for two years now
in like such annoying conditions on an
airplane like it's tight it's hot
wearing a mask and i just i felt so
excited for them
that is lovely i was going to say
something totally different until you
told me about the emotional response on
board and that makes me feel like pilot
crying that's really nice yeah no it's
just like first of all it's torture if
you still want to wear your mask like do
you but you don't have to wear it now
and it just that feels like a real
signal like we're coming out of this you
know yeah it feels good that's great i
was gonna say like the trip is coming up
and i'm just
just excited i was gonna say like i'll
believe it when i see it like i know i'm
gonna get on a flight and like there's
gonna be someone's just gonna yell at me
like no i do think that like the amount
of videos we're gonna see about like in
off in air flying like
fighting you know between people
passengers like you know how we've been
seeing so many people refusing to wear
masks i just think we're gonna see a lot
more videos like that people fighting
you know like because people are very
divided like i was reading comments you
know brian obviously is
a travel like news source and on his
instagram he posted about it asking
people what they think and like the
comments people were fighting so hard
like i'll be wearing my mask forever
another person was like freedom so like
people are still still super divided i
think we're gonna see a lot of fighting
videos yeah i mean
personal choice now which is lovely yeah
that could just be me like my one of my
worst fears is ending up on like a video
like that that goes viral like people
fighting on an airplane like that will
never be me i'll get off the plane
terrible if somebody starts fighting me
like i will get off the plane i will
deplane i will d-board as a personal
choice i think i'm going to bring a mask
on planes and use them when i enter the
restroom oh because i really enjoy it
like right spot i couldn't agree more i
don't want to know what the bathroom
smells like it could smell great it
could smell terrible i love the mystery
of not knowing if the bathroom smells
bad on an airplane it's so
perfectly put yeah i completely agree or
even like the bathrooms in the airport
yeah what they also need to do now that
masks are mandatory like are not
mandatory or not mandatory maybe they
make one that has like a nice scent air
freshener yeah like a glade should come
out with one or febreze yeah just like
something that it's more like an air
freshener for the nose love make sure
that you can't smell those things you
don't want to smell listerine should
come out with their own
yeah that's good too yeah love the idea
of wearing it in the bathroom and i
completely agree yeah bathrooms in
general they're just gross yeah you know
also like one of my toxic traits is
before the pandemic like before
when we used to never wear masks on
planes my go-to thing to do in the
bathroom on planes was to pop my
blackheads there's something about like
the pressurized air
in the bathroom in the bathroom like in
the mirror there's something about the i
think like the science of the air that
makes it like prime pimple popping
season but like i do know how disgusting
that is so like knowing that's what i do
in the bathroom i can only imagine what
other people do in the bathroom and i
agree like i will be packing a mask for
the toilet
that's something i didn't know about you
really that
you didn't have to share it
like no i feel like it's very common i'm
not gonna lie like i think i've shared
that before and people were like yeah me
too nope
i don't think that there's anybody else
on planet earth that spends extra time
in the bathroom popping their blackheads
you know one thing about me is like if
i'm shopping in a dressing room and like
i'm trying on clothes like if i see a
mirror like i will pop a blackhead that
i understand a little bit more like
everywhere i'll be at a restaurant like
looking in the mirror like there's just
a mirror in the restaurant i will pop a
blackhead maybe it's just because you're
smaller but like
i cannot fit in a bathroom at all on an
airplane yeah it's just crazy it's so
tight i want to get out of there i have
to scrunch my head i can't even imagine
brian in the [ __ ] airplane bathroom
your knees like it's just totally just a
terrible experience do you remember i
just want to get out as quickly as
possible remember when covet first
started and people were saying like
airplanes are gonna be changed forever
like the way we sit we're never gonna
sit three and three again it's gonna be
like individual and then we're gonna be
sitting backwards church but and like
all these like um sketches came out of
what airplanes are gonna look like and
nothing has changed yeah that's because
the people who propose them aren't the
ones paying for the plane to be changed
totally and the people who are paying
for the plane to be changed know that
everybody will forget that this ever was
even a thing 100
um okay so dewey are you ready to dive
into the fast five story
i beat you no but you didn't do it i
beat you no but you didn't do it i beat
the christians
i beat the croons no you have to say are
you right okay here are the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning
toast i got it no
um and today's
today's episode that's honestly so
[ __ ] up like that's my thing no
literally the student became the master
wow
that's crazy today's episode is brought
to you by omaze if you've ever dreamed
of having a chance to win awesome prizes
like a karaoke with charlize theron
going to space on virgin galactic
winning a tesla then you've got to check
out omaze the new way to give back to
charity and have fun while doing it
here's how omaze works you enter for the
chance to win something amazing and at
the same time you can donate to support
great causes it's a fun and easy way for
non-profits to raise money and for you
to win big prizes like a hundred
thousand dollars so if you go to
omaze.com toast and you select something
like the financial freedom one the
deadline is to enter on april 30th so
hurry for your chance to win and if you
missed the deadline don't worry they're
giving away a hundred thousand dollars
again next month and through your
donations omaze has raised more than 150
million dollars to support over 350
nonprofits around the world so everyone
deserves a chance to live their dream
and with oma's extraordinary prizes are
within reach for everyone so right now
they're doing the financial freedom
prize it's a hundred thousand dollars
like what would i do with a hundred
thousand dollars i would charter a jet
go to church and caicos and
eat everything inside um
and they're doing it again next month
but this one is going until april 30th
so you can still
enter to win and by doing that you're
supporting a wonderful charity and maybe
winning a hundred thousand dollars so
hurry and enter today for your chance to
win a hundred thousand dollars or any
other life changing prizes and
experiences at omaze.com toast plus you
can receive 20 extra entries when you
enter with code toast 20. so that's
omaze.com
toast and that code is toast20 no
purchase necessary to enter a win visit
omaze.com toast for official rules
today's episode is also brought to you
by thuma your bedroom deserves a refresh
and now is the perfect time to elevate
the most important room in your home
with thuma thumb will practice an
intentional less is more design
philosophy for the bedroom with clean
lines subtle curves and lifestyle
enhancing details thumb proves that
simplicity is true is the truest form of
sophistication
so introducing the bed by thuma it is
handcrafted from eco-friendly high
quality upcycled wood and you'll find
beautiful unique variations in natural
grain the minimalist design feature
which features japanese joinery helps
elevate any space it's super supportive
for your mattress it's breathable made
to naturally minimize noise and create
space it's made for how you live so the
bed by thuma is backed with a lifetime
warranty ships right to your door in
three easy to maneuver boxes and it
takes about five ish minutes to assemble
with no tools required as people who
have set up furniture together and
nearly killed each other um five minutes
is a very small price to pay for a
gorgeous bed by thuma along with the bed
thuma also offers other bedroom
essentials to elevate bedtime so they
have the nightstand the side table and
the tray and they all perfectly
complement the bed thummer works with
one tree planted to plant one tree for
every bed and nightstand sold and all of
their essentials are green guard
certified so ordering with thuma was a
really pleasant experience the styles
are really gorgeous and simple i feel
like they're very in trend right now and
if you're you know you move during covet
or you're moving out
check out thumb i think you'll really
enjoy it
create the feeling of checking into your
favorite boutique hotel suite but at
home with the bed by thuma and now go to
thuma dot co slash toast and use the
code toast to receive a 25 credit
towards your purchase of the bed plus
free shipping and in the continental us
that's t h u m a dot c o slash toast
enter co toast at checkout for 25 credit
thuma dot co slash toast enter code
toast all right ben you ready for the
fast five i'm not gonna lie they're uh
they're blank okay well the first thing
is like a picture that just sent me into
a spiral late last night um drake is
hugging taylor swift in a throwback
photo and the theories have begun so
taylor swift fans can't shake off
drake's latest instagram post the rapper
shared a throwback photo on monday of
himself giving taylor a hug from behind
as she holds on to him and nestles her
head in his arm
and he
wrote the caption they too soft to
understand the meaning of hard work and
he snuck in this this photo in the last
slide of a five-part carousel which also
featured a picture of his five-year-old
four-year-old son adonis throwing up a
peace sign but the easter egg loving
swifties are quaking and they never miss
a beat with the theories that taylor
swift and drake are collaborating on
music um
so people are saying this is a throwback
photo i don't know how
that's been confirmed or denied like why
would drake randomly post a photo from
five years ago
now here are some of the theories like
it was the fifth photo in the carousel
the fifth album is 1989 1989 is coming
um and drake has long been a part of
taylor's series like when she was on the
cover of entertainment weekly um she was
wearing this jacket with all these
different pins and one of them was drake
people thought maybe that was going to
be a collab on lover but it wasn't so
drake isn't new to the taylor swift era
i thought this picture was like very
cute and like you know i'm really happy
for taylor she's in a good relationship
but like look isn't that like a really
cute pick
what do you think it means
i have no idea people are just saying
it's a throwback photo like how do you
know let me see
like there's no date on it there's no
way to know if it's old people are like
well that looks like her she is ageless
like she looks the same from the last 10
years i have no idea if this is a new
world photo could be new it could be old
i'm not sure thank you for that very
helpful inside sure what do you think it
means
um just a casual like hey look i hung
out with taylor this week well you're
saying that she is in a very serious
relationship with another fella yeah
another fellow yeah joe alwyn so
i would assume that it's not romantic i
don't believe it's romantic even though
like i kind of wanted to be
and uh do you think this means they're
gonna do a song together
i think that it's an incredibly random
thing to post so i would assume that
there's some meaning behind it yeah the
people that it's not romantic then it's
probably music the reason why people are
quaking is because it's so [ __ ]
random it's very random and weird
i think that like a song with them too
would be the like the best song on earth
it would crush it would crush it would
be like
you know like call me maybe in the sense
like it would just be everywhere
i love call me maybe me too it's a great
song hey i just met you and this is
crazy
it's a great song such a good song i'm
just thinking what that no would be
great and like taylor's in my opinion
collaborated with people that like i
just think
stink and like if she could pick
somebody great like
she's very rarely with somebody on her
own level yes she does unique
collaborations she like picks these
weirdos no weirdos but like i think
she's not doing like big time collabs
with all these other people she does
like and most recently she did haym she
loves to do ed sheeran she's done future
um
but nothing like enormous comes to mind
i think one of her greatest
collaborations is her song very uh not
known with b.o.b
called
i love that song yeah what's it called
hold on
i like literally i own it on itunes
taylor's i loved b.o.b me too what
happened to him
i don't know
um
both of us
i
wish i
was strong
enough to
lift not one but
both of us
such a good song amazing but you're
right she's not like big into collabs i
feel like a lot of artists like make
their bones off of collabs or maybe i
just forgot that she had all of those
collabs and like the last album which
like i know everybody loved like i just
like didn't love it which one
the i didn't like that song with uh what
is his name bony bear
oh well there were two so he was
featured on folklore and evermore she
had two recent albums oh she did they
were like sister albums they're very
similar um i could write a whole
dissertation on why are more is better
but um i liked the bony bear collabs
they just for me i think that was that
the album where everything was very it
was a covet album there were yeah there
was nothing that ever like reached a
chorus
no
that's not it it felt like it never
reached a high it was always very it was
an album made for for quarantine so it
was very like emo it's very bony bear
which is why she collabs with bony bear
understood so yeah that album i hated
and uh bony there this is so offensive
i'm sorry i it just like wasn't my thing
and i love taylor no you do you do i do
i just like that
maybe that's just like not my type of
taylor music no you're into like pop
queen taylor now
and that's why i think that her and
drake would make a great song yeah and i
think if she's going back to pop i mean
she's been doing kind of like
alternative these last two albums but
her pop is like her her thing and red
the re-release was like very country so
if she does go back to pop or just like
popular music and she does a collab with
drake i think it would be so sick yeah
it would be amazing i hope that's what
we're getting there's been a lot of
rumors on jamaa like taylor dropping
something but nothing's come out it's
actually a big week for music um this
friday
luke homes is coming out with a new song
and he announced a new album in june so
like thank god
and like this is really niche but i
don't know if i told you about this
there was there's this girl i follow on
tick tock and she wrote this country
song and she played the verse and the
chorus
on tick tock and it blew up and so it's
been months and months and months and
i'm just like waiting for her to release
it her name is meg maroney the song is
called
heartbroken in a hair salon and it comes
out on friday and like i don't think
i've really ever been so excited in my
life it's so good yeah called bernadette
she had us 10 am so good what music are
you looking forward to this summer ben
simple plan has a new tour
they're coming uh to the seaport and to
asberry park and you already committed
to coming with me so we have to go to
that i don't remember actually i don't
remember committing but i think that we
now actually are going to be in texas
we're busy so sad yeah we might not be
here we might be here though actually no
i think it's right after your new york
show and there are still limited tickets
available thank you girl with no job.com
slash tour um i think it's that weekend
so we could go if they were planned
still releasing new year's yeah they
just released a new song oh i don't
remember the name so you obviously like
i love it no i haven't i haven't really
listened to it yet but i love them and i
think that that will be great and
speaking of other niche artists i've
played uh you for
him for you before it's called games we
play you're obsessed you found them on
tick tock right this guy emiyan is
unbelievable like his voices he just
signed to
i'm gonna butcher the name of it too
something ramen
that like also does panic at the disco
fallout boy like he really just like
signs like a serious label and he
started on tick tock
uh that's where i found him right he is
like
fallout boy blink 182 reincarnated right
into just an unbelievable artist and
he's releasing he sent me a bunch of
unreleased tracks
and like yeah i'm that guy that gets
unreleased
isn't it like so crazy the impact tick
tock has on the music industry yes it's
also crazy
to think about the way that the music
industry operated before somebody could
just drop a song
and we could listen to it and like it
right and it could become a huge without
anything without anything yeah no tick
tock has left the music industry quaking
i think yeah
yeah and like it's the way that it
should be like if you then want to
operationalize yourself and like go on a
tour you need help yeah but like if
somebody wants to listen to your music
they should be able to listen to it
like it's always crazy to think about
the artists who started on social media
like shawn mendes one of the biggest
artists in the world vine bieber
bieber luke combs a lot of people don't
know that he was a viner yeah it's just
crazy yeah and it's great and i'm upset
it never happened to me like i could be
a pop star right now if i just tried
harder and what's great is that i am
remembering that like maybe years ago
i said that tick tock was ruining music
yeah and i'm here to say that
it puts people in a spotlight for a
second but if you don't belong there it
very quickly vanishes no and it's really
crazy how like people can blow up and
like really make careers out of it they
can but i'm saying
those bad ones that like shouldn't be
getting the attention that they did
they also filter out yeah yeah but like
do you know who tate mccray is i know
the name
she's like touring right now everyone's
obsessed with her she had like one song
go viral and take talk and then another
and another now she's like a full-blown
artist yeah it's just crazy yeah that's
amazing and you did mention that if you
like you could be a pop star you're
choosing not to be it's true it's true
it's like when you have so many talents
it's like which one do i lean into but
sometimes when i'm getting ready to go
on stage and like i love love love doing
comedy truckers for my comedy um i do
but it's very um like mentally taxing
like
i'm just like always very like pent up
you know before i go on stage i'm like
very nervous and stuff and i always
think like if i was going on stage right
now to like perform like songs i would
be so happy yeah because it's
i'm not going to say it's easier but no
but like it's like you have it all
memorized already like you know and it's
fun it's fun i think it's more fun not
easier i do wonder how hard it is to
sing like that like how hard on your
lungs and vocal cords to sing like that
for an hour and a half well you know
that happens a lot a lot of people get
nodes john mayer and adele have famously
had the same surgery
lea michele got it in glee so she didn't
like actually get it but it's you can
get like vocaled out
scary thankfully it hasn't happened to
me yet yeah um so i guess we'll just
have to wait and see what happens with
taylor and drake but like i just feel
like all signs point to positive but
this could also just be like another
taylor swift thing that's mundane but we
are making it like a whole thing and
it's actually nothing maybe he just
liked that photo of himself he was you
know cleaning out his garage and he
found it no no no there's no reason he
posts that maybe he was cleaning out his
garage it means something he might have
been cleaning out his garage okay um
okay next story is about the kardashians
uh current lawsuit with blac chyna blac
chyna is suing them okay
for like financial emotional damages she
believes that they had a part in
canceling her e-show with rob
called robin chyna do you remember they
had their own spin-off for a season
she says
she says it was very successful
and the kardashians were responsible for
getting it canceled which i don't really
feel like makes a lot of sense i think
it was cancelled because her and rob
broke up but whatever
um
but the
the proceedings have started and like
they're at in court with blac chyna it's
crazy and all these sketches are coming
out of people who are obviously there's
no media in the room but people are
drawing sketches of like the kardashians
blac chyna in the same room um
and with jury selection there was a
little drama so the kardashians were
visibly annoyed with the sex tape
comments that happened during jury
selection so the kardashians and the
jenners were less than thrilled to hear
about kim kardashian's sex tape during
the jury selection for the family's
pending trial against blac chyna
oh wait they're swimming black china i
thought blac chyna was doing them
page six was inside the la superior
court when the kardashian attorney
michael rhodes asked a group of
potential jurors if they had a strong
positive or negative feeling about
reality television one potential juror a
man who appeared to be in his 50s or 60s
claimed that he'd never seen keeping up
with the kardashians but he said i have
watched kim kardashian sex tape sex tape
and i don't think i can be impartial on
this case so when picking
jurors for any sort of
trial it's important that like the
people
in who end up in the jury like have no
preconceived notions like
i think when jackie went to do jury
they were like a landlord was suing
the
tenant no the tenant was doing the
landlord for bed bugs so someone was
like if you've had bed bugs you can't
be impartial so whatever like you can't
have any real strong opinions so i guess
she said she said bed bugs jackie said
she had bed bugs i think so she could
bounce oh she she made it up i believe
don't quote me on that
so it's much harder when you're like a
public figure because more people have
strong opinions on you than a normal
landlord or tenant so the guy said he
had seen the sex tape and then the
response elicited a roar of laughter
from other people
sitting in the audience and that remark
made chloe you know she went over to kim
fixed her hair and was comforting her
sister and then kris jenner shook her
head after the same man reiterated to
the judge that it would be difficult for
him to serve as a juror because he would
be replaying that sex tape over and over
again in his head
kim kept her gaze forward towards the
front of the room chloe looked visibly
annoyed by the comment and carried the
same facial expression with her as her
sisters and chris walked out of the
courtroom for a break
um so chloe kim and chris are sitting in
the front row of the audience kylie
jenner is there too
and rob kardashian was not present
obviously blac chyna was in the
courtroom with her lawyer and her mom
um two people
two groups of potential jurors about 76
people have been asked questions and
they're planning a third panel of
questions um on tuesday so i just wanted
to who's being sued for a while right
and who's suing so ease keeping on the
kardashians was on for 20 seasons and
during that time several spin-off shows
including rob in china debuted
um
and in 2017 china filed a lawsuit
against the entire kardashian jenner
family
um over claims of assault battery
domestic violence defamation and
interference with prospective economic
relations so interfering with
prospective economic relations is her
saying that they got her show cancelled
okay
um she's she is seeking more than 40
million dollars for losses of earning
damages and more than 60 million dollars
in loss of future earning capacity
damages and the kardashian engineers
responded to china's claim with a
lawsuit of their own
um and they say that she violently
attacked rob so she sued them and then
they sued her back
so now this courtroom is for them suing
her back and they're all in court for
what she did to rob
no
that she just said no so
there so she sued them i don't believe
she won and now they're suing her back
for suing them i got it but their
countersuit is is including oh that she
violently attacked rob but i think
they're suing for you know an overall
thing
this is so messy and it just brings me
back to the robin china days
terrible that juror is such a dick i
know it's like i can't even you watch
the first episode of kardashians with me
right the fact that this is like still a
thing after all kim has accomplished
she's becoming a lawyer she's helped
people get out of jail she's a billion
dollar business owner like the fact that
this is still at the forefront of
people's minds is so [ __ ] sad it can
be at the forefront of people's minds
because when you release a sex tape you
release a sex tape she didn't release a
sex tape by the way when a sex tape is
leaked a sex tape is leaked like you're
you're forever like
watch because we just watched
pammy and tom and that's like
significantly older and tammy and tom
what did i say
tom and tom tom wait tommy and pam tommy
and pam
uh pamela anderson forever will be
associated with her leaked sex tape but
tommy but tommy won't yeah he will why
because i think he is i don't okay and
that show really highlighted how it
affected her way more than him did you
not take that away from that it
definitely did but i do think that it
affected him and he
forever has that with him but that's not
the point it's just easier but i'm just
saying that it's easier for a man to
move on sure that again not the point of
this at all
i'm saying that when a sex tape is
leaked or released it's always something
that that person unfortunately has to
live with that being said
there is no reason why that juror needed
to say that just keep it to yourself
totally like why are you such a dick
like it's such a no but also i just feel
like kim's affects her more than other
people's
like there have been many many celebrity
sex tapes and i feel like i don't even
think of it sometimes like paris hilton
had one i don't even remember no one's
even as close to as famous as kim yeah
and
no one wants to tear somebody down more
than people want to tear down kim that's
true
that's so true because they don't like
they don't like how she got famous
they link she's famous she got from the
start from the tape versus paris hilton
is famous for being rich
and cool but it's just so played out
like grow up move on like kim has
accomplished so much like being like kim
kardashian have famous have a sex tape
and like being a kim hater is like such
a losery personality trait like i will
hate you if that is the way you feel
yeah
agreed um so like that just sucks at
like she i mean i'm sure she doesn't
[ __ ] care but like it's embarrassing
no i'm sure she does care and it sucks
yeah and like this blac chyna thing is
just like it's giving losery energy like
and i'm i you know
i feel like she thought she could sue
them because they're like so rich and
whatever and she might win
but
i feel like she got played you play
stupid games you win stupid prizes now
they're suing her totally and she'll
probably lose money right of course well
when you sue someone
like if i were to sue you
and i lose
i have to pay your legal bills that's
how it works how interesting yeah
because like i just randomly decided to
sue you you incur all these costs
and if i had no ground to stand on
you shouldn't have to be out that money
so when you see someone and you lose you
have you incur there that's why not like
it's always a drastic thing to sue
someone because you have to know you can
really win i understand in order to
effectively get paid
so
um we'll keep you updated on that trial
um things seem to be
very tense over there in calabasas and
we're gonna keep moving on with a story
that is like the craziest thing i've
ever heard in my life and it's brought
to you by all birds spring is just
around the corner and the warmer weather
is perfect for exercising outdoors
so um if you haven't checked out all
birds yet whether you love to spend time
outside running and being athletic or
you just love a comfortable shoe like if
you travel a lot for me all birds are
the go-to airplane shoe um you've gotta
check out their new tree dasher two
they just released them it's the next
generation of their best-selling
insanely comfortable running shoe that's
made from a mix of natural materials
that's better for you and better for the
planet they feel so comfortable lighter
than air for me like when i'm on tour
walking through airports there's just so
many long corridors hallways escalators
and it feels good to know that my shoes
are not going to give me blisters i'm
not going to get uncomfortable um and i
love the tree dasher too so they add
comfort to every run with lighter more
responsive foam it has extra grip and an
improved fit to keep you running and
nature winning so their lighter more
responsive foam adds spring to every
step
and the the materials are super
sustainable it's sugar cane based sweet
foam mines midsoles that are made with
the first carbon negative
efva resin their shoelaces are made from
recycled plastic bottles so you can feel
good knowing your shoes are comfortable
and they're also helping the planet so
if you want to discover your perfect
pair of all birds spring forward with
the all birds tree dasher 2 at
allbirds.com that's a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot-com spring forward with the all
birds tree dasher 2 running shoe
discover your perfect pair at
allbirds.com today a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
shoes are made with sugar
yeah they're sustainable queen very cool
ready they cash me outside girl bad baby
how about that
how about it
not bad baby
it's bad baby it is it's b h a d b h oh
yes yes yes i mean it could be bahad
bahabi
but i'm gonna go and guess it's bad baby
yeah i know exactly what she looks like
i remember we played her for halloween
remember
so she bought a house in florida a
mansion for 6.1 million dollars and she
paid all cash
isn't that crazy
janelle bregoli obviously known as bad
baby who was launched to internet
stardom for fighting dr phil
now has added something else to her name
a property owner she's a florida native
and her tv interview racked up millions
and millions of views she now has 16
million instagram followers she shelled
out 6.1 million dollars for a boca raton
i don't see bad baby as a boca raton
queen
it's a very elder jewish area i don't
know how the neighbors are going to feel
um she shelled out 6.1 million dollars
in an all-cash deal her home is 9 200
square feet
seven bedrooms
seven bathrooms and it comes packed with
amenities um
it was completely redone in 2020 it's
considered an estate it has a two-story
guest house an acre of land hurricane
impact windows porcelain tiles
throughout the pictures are really
stunning it's a modern clean
gray
palace it has an eat-in chef's kitchen a
walk-in pantry top-of-the-line
appliances and the primary bedroom which
is located on the first floor boasts
three large walk-in closets and an
outside jacuzzi area her ensuite
bathroom features a walk-in rain shower
with two shower heads a waterfall middle
shower head and just
lots of gorgeous
very detailed she's got a billiards room
i mean because the listing was online
this house is [ __ ] huge there's a
million pictures her bed her bathroom
has a couch inside of it she's got a big
ass pool big ass lawn you know she did
venture into music she did a little
makeup collab it's extremely unclear
where her um
money comes from i know where her money
comes from
i'm sorry she also owns a five bedroom
seven bathroom estate in the same
neighborhood
which is now on the market for three
points so she currently has two homes a
three million dollar one and a six
million dollar one
she has a deal with atlantic records
even though they have since parted ways
so she had a record deal she earns
millions in brand deals with online
retailers like fashion nova
i wish i had said it but
i was literally about to say she got all
of the money from fashion nova she is
like the fashion nova personally
and she also works with copycat beauty
and she launched her own indie music
label worldwide her music has been
streamed more than 1.5 billion times
really like and i feel like in streams
it's like not a lot it's not it's not
that's not that much okay um all the
money is coming from the brand deals
with nova um
good for her that's insane to me i hope
that nobody in like fort lauderdale
takes this personally but like i feel
like she should have bought that house
in fort lauderdale i hear she's much
more her brand is very fort lauderdale a
little less bokeh i agree bokeh is a
strange odd it seems odd
but maybe she is just that personality
on tv and really at home she is a uh
nice jewish girl right like maybe she's
not danielle bergoli maybe she's
danielle cohen and she just changed her
name
to do this whole thing with dr phil it
would be just like de blasio william
wilhelm changing your name bill de
blasio yeah maybe she's just been
playing us the whole time she went on
the thing she's faking it the whole time
danielle cohen lives in boca yeah no i
have to say this is extremely off-brand
like if there's anything you know about
boca it's like very slow
very retiree vibes um very very not
danielle
no but this danielle cohen theory how's
legs it's interesting right it's very
interesting yeah maybe she just like
lied about everything i just can't
believe she gives people so much money
because people don't go on dr phil like
that without intention right no i mean
paying all cash for a house is insane
like even like major major celebrities
have mortgages i remember with chrissy
teigen the mortgage rates these days oh
that's true maybe she's just being a
smart investor she could be they're now
at six percent wow
that's a lot yeah so
it doesn't pay to take out the mortgage
if you can do it in cash i mean she said
six million dollars chilling in a bank
account like to me that's insane
when did you go on dr phil we're
literally forgetting that this is like
10 years old no it's not 10 but it's
like five okay five six years well i'll
tell you actually they said she went on
i think in 2016.
um
[Music]
2017.
okay
five years her first year she probably
made the most money so many brand deals
and if she had a smart financial manager
put the money in the market earn some
interest and all of a sudden cash queen
no like i knew she was a cash queen i
just didn't know she was like you know
buying six million dollar homes for all
cash to me that's just insane like
that's what i'm really shocked about
yeah it's good for her it's crazy
i'm shook it's cool good for her happy
for her and just a little bit jealous no
no need to be jealous gorgeous home
really gorgeous home good for her
we love to see you know women in
business yeah whatever um okay next
story is a story that's been developing
over the last couple years has finally
been put to uh
an end
mac miller's drug supplier was sentenced
to nearly 11 years in prison so one of
the men who supplied mac miller with the
fentanyl laced pills that led to his
overdose has been sentenced to 10 years
and 11 months in prison his name is ryan
revis he pled guilty to one felony count
of distributing fentanyl he was one of
three charged in the rapper's september
2018 fatal overdose and according to
rolling stone he requested a five-year
sentence claiming he was just a
middleman and had no idea that the pills
he supplied were laced prosecutors
requested that his sentence be 12 and a
half years
and before the judge handed down rebus
sentence on monday mac miller's mom
karen myers addressed the court she said
my life went dark the moment malcolm
left the world malcolm was my person
more than a son we had a bond in a
kinship that was deep and special and
irreplaceable we spoke nearly every day
about everything his life plans music
dreams
mack would never have knowingly taken a
pill with fentanyl ever he wanted to
live and was excited about the future
the hole in my heart will always be
there
so um this has been going on for a while
but the trial has finally ended he's
been sentenced to 11 years mac miller
was 26 when he died at his home in l.a
from an overdose of alcohol cocaine and
fentanyl
was it an overdose or was it fentanyl
it says cocaine and fentanyl
an overdose of alcohol cocaine and
fentanyl
and the case for the third man who was
charged is still ongoing
um
so yeah terrible just so sad whenever i
think about mac miller it's like one of
those things it's just like it's
horrible it's horrible
and it's a constant reminder don't do
drugs but if you do be safe test them
yeah because like this [ __ ] it's it's
oddly it like there was a there was a
period like five months ago where it was
kind of common you know
like people are just dying it happened
all over the country it's really really
common right now you have to be so
careful so bizarre to me that a
drug dealer whose livelihood depends
on people being alive to buy your drugs
would intentionally put something in it
that would kill someone
it's right so weird i don't know how
something else i don't know how it works
like who laces the drugs and why in the
drug chain and why like why why are you
putting things in it
there's no reason no totally if anything
the opposite putting like the most
addictive substance whatever that's
going to make somebody live forever and
buy your drugs right no totally i don't
get like the point of fentanyl it
doesn't make any sense we should
probably do some research because there
must be a reason i feel like this is
probably um like a closure finally for
mac miller's mom i follow her on
instagram she's like a really sweet
woman and this is just like so sad and
i'm just you know praying for everyone
the whole thing's terrible terrible um
we have a lot of like legal news today
like a lot of trials because our fifth
and final story is about the amber heard
and johnny depp trial which is just
chaos and it's brought to you by
manscaped ladies have you started spring
cleaning yet the carpets need cleaning
the drapes need dusting and you and your
man's lawn need mowing spring has sprung
and the global leaders in below the
waist grooming have the best tools for
cleaning aisle 5 in your pants join the
other 4 million individuals worldwide
who trust manscaped by going to
manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping with code toast you're a
manscaped girly i bought you the whole
set that was a that was a great ad yeah
like the copy it's not over yet but okay
cool but i wanted to talk to you about
your experience with manscaped all your
your they have great razors yeah that
being said like i'm not using that [ __ ]
on my face and on my well you clean it
yeah but still have you manscaped has
the full package your household needs
for spring cleaning this year the
performance package 4.0 was the only
tool you need to keep the lawn smooth
and smelling fresh to start off your
spring cleaning use the manscaped
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer to get the most
precise shape to keep both your hedges
clean and smooth did we mention it's
waterproof as well no need to worry
about watering your grass with this tool
it's equipped with an led light
so you know exactly what you're doing
down there this tool is so good good you
want to buy one for yourself after you
you see how smooth it is they're also
raising awareness for the most common
form of cancer in men aged 15 to 35 and
they're giving support for fighters
survivors and families impacted by
testicular cancer as a part of the we
save balls initiative they um
are offering a code so if you can get 20
off and free shipping with
codetoast.manscape.com
it's 20 off and free shipping with the
code toast at manscaped.com
out with the old grooming habits and in
with the new manscaped um
perfect gift for the boyfriend cousin
brother anyone in your life they have
all great grooming products the razors
obviously they have a lot of they have
underwear they have great travel cases
they have a lot of good stuff so make
sure to check out manscape.com and the
code is toast for 20 off and free
shipping great razors okay so tmz
is letting us know what's going down do
you know about the johnny depp amber
heard trial i just know that like
there's some drama yeah so they were
married
and then afterwards you know what amber
heard from she's an actress
she's not as famous as johnny depp but
she's pretty much she's from aquaman
she's from aquaman with jason momoa sure
anything else she's like a superhero
girly i don't know because i don't
superhero yeah cool so she
they had like this crazy messy divorce
like lots of trials whatever and then
she wrote an article
um saying that she was physically abused
in her journey with physical abuse and
made it she didn't say i don't think she
said exactly it was johnny but she made
it abundantly clear that it was
and he is now suing her for 100 million
dollars claiming he never physically
abused her and now their marriage is
like on trial and it's so messy and
there was like the story that had come
out where johnny depp said that um
amber crapped in the bed
and like left the poop there
so
that was like
sounds like me
in their divorce that was like a story
that was told during trial like people
were quaking about it and now the poop
is coming up again at this particular
trial and he's taking the stand on
tuesday
which is today in the bitter defamation
lawsuit against amber heard and he's
expected to talk about an incident he
says ended the marriage which is when
amber or a friend it's not sure who
defecated on his side of the bed there's
a picture but like the picture of the
duty is
blurred out but like the trail
is there do you want to see it no okay
so johnny's suing amber for 50 million
dollars claiming she lied when she
accused him of physically abusing her
and she's counter-suing him for 100
million dollars for defamation claiming
he coordinated a smear campaign against
her just hearing the word smear after
seeing that piece of duty is just it's
not what i needed so a key date in the
trial is april 22nd 2016 when amber was
having a birthday party for herself at
their downtown la penthouse depp showed
up late and decided he would bail which
he says enraged amber and amber said
johnny threw a magnum wine bottle at her
before leaving we're told the
housekeeper called johnny depp the next
morning and told him someone had crapped
on his side of the bed and then put the
covers over it he thinks amber wanted
him to unsuspectingly hop in the bed and
sit on the poop
depp believes that amber heard or one of
her friends were the culprit amber has
said one of their yorkshire terriers was
the one who took the dump but depp has
scoffed at that saying the poop was too
large to be um
coming out of a three or four pound dog
johnny has said the pooping incident was
the final straw in their marriage
and
the poop is on trial
amber's on trial
if you were what would it take for me
like what would i have to do to make you
so angry to take a dump on my side of
the bed
nothing
i don't think i could physically take a
dog not in a toilet it's just not like a
normal
response to anything it's so disgusting
it's just weird like i would sooner take
a dump on your side of the bed as a joke
right then like as like uh
i'm getting back at you so i'm [ __ ]
in my own bed do you think it's my bed
too i just sleep on the other side do
you think that like you could physically
get a [ __ ] out of your butt
not being on the toilet like i feel like
i couldn't squat [ __ ] yeah
because again like literally three weeks
ago i [ __ ] in the bed no but you were
sick that's different you had no control
of your body would you consciously
intentionally
be able to squat over the bed and and
dump i feel like my body wouldn't work
that way unless you dumped in the toilet
and picked it out with a glove it would
have to be
time and place maybe you had like
two subway foot longs iced coffee
you're holding it for a long time
and you strategically wait until you're
about to burst
right you could be strategic about it
that's true you could be strategic about
it but they were also they were having a
party the night before so like you know
when you drink a lot sometimes i think
when you do drugs you have to like poop
it's just yeah but not normal but if you
were like [ __ ] up like doing you know
drinking a lot maybe maybe your
inhibitions are lowered you can force
out a dump on the bed look i know
nothing about this story
seems very very odd
and
there's nothing worse than hearsay on if
somebody hit someone like did you hit
her or not right right and you know it's
crazy terrible it's crazy how the public
like
especially on the internet like people
do not believe amber heard
like people are universally siding with
johnny depp on this i mean i want to
right because he's johnny depp and i
love him yeah so i don't know the
caribbean i don't know what the truth is
and i'm not like super invested in these
two like i remember they were married i
don't remember much like i'm not i'm not
really caught up on the details here so
he sued her
she said that he hit her she wrote an
article he sued her but not saying that
it was him uh i don't think she said by
name but she said like her ex-husband or
whatever got it
he
then doing her and she's countering and
she's counter-striking and she's
counter-suing for him long
it's a mess
so much money wasted yeah i mean
the the real winners are the lawyers 100
terrible okay um okay so that's like
all the fast stories lots of legal news
legality everywhere um
yeah and those are the past life stories
ben i'm so grateful that you joined us
i'm
i love seeing you even though i see you
every day i love seeing you as well
don't forget to use code blunge at
sportssociety.com bwnj
spritzsociety.com and that's our show
don't you normally leave an easter egg
like one of those things you still do
that like where like people go and like
write an emoji or something
yeah like sometimes you do that i would
just love to know uh
if people want to guess the new flavor
sure
they can leave an emoji of the fruit
that they think it will be on our
instagram um thank you ben for being
here toasters we've got a great week
we've got tasha tomorrow remy bader
thursday and jackie's back
on friday so it's gonna be a great week
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast life
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcast anywhere podcasting we found out
what's butterfly institute your public
radio i don't kiss box all the places
wherever there's some podcast venus even
faster everybody better beautiful
smartphone love you man love you guys
have a great day and we'll see you
tomorrow